front-end development at 2018 what's in
your sec if someone finds a bigger topic
to talk about please let me know I
handed in this proposal and figured out
laughs pretty well I'm not sure this was
a good idea but let's see my last dry
one was one hour twenty really make 55
hopefully let me quickly introduce
myself I'm Stefan I'm from Berlin
my main interest these days is
open-source I sometimes teach CSS and
note in Berlin I run a few meetups and I
work for contentful and contentful is a
content management infrastructure in the
cloud so when you want to build
JavaScript apps or whatever apps and you
don't want to set up your own server
with your kind of management system and
you just want to have a scalable
flexible system you can give content
full try and I do mainly front-end
development for quite a while and it's a
big love in my life and when I started
front-end development this was basically
20 2011 and the role of a front-end
engineer I'm not even sure if it was an
engineer at this point and was quite
different than it was today so I
literally had drop into race interviews
2011 where it was like yeah the
server-side developers are the real
programmers and the front-end engineers
are making making it pretty right it's
just moving some CSS around but now we
have 2018 is that me and it looks a lot
more like this so over the last few year
years the front-end became actually
engineering and not only engineering it
became engineering with new tools and
practices every year and keeping track
with all the stuff that is released and
that is discovered it's really really
hard so this is basically my inbox and
you see that ran out we recorded this
there's actually an email coming in from
NPM telling me about new stuff so it's
really really hard to keep track with
all the changes because we have new
stuff it feels like we have new stuff
every month so let's talk about what's
in the front end engineer in second 2018
and live lets me give you a quick
warning what I will tell you is highly
opinionated there's way more stuff out
there and I'm not covering religious
question
few angular reacts whirl with it
whatever is your jam MPM more yarn
competition is good right I think NPM is
better but it doesn't matter right and
recently there was a tweet from James
long he is the maintainer of prettier
who has heard of prettier that's the
tool that finally helps her to figure
out the problems we have with code style
changes so he said I never used
typescript I never used parcel and
you've never used thumb I never used
several s I never used view and I don't
feel behind and that's really hard for
me but this is the truth we shouldn't
feel behind he chooses his deck am i
doing something he chooses his deck and
he just shifts with it and one thing
that I want to tell you is when you
choose your tool stack ask yourself why
you should use a tool don't just pick
your tool because it's fancy right now
or it's doing something a good tool
should solve a problem it should keep
you productive and it should make you
happy and we had one year ago or two
years ago we had the release of Redux
right every Redux is a tool for state
management and react applications I can
use in any framework and it was from one
to the other day it was in every stack
and then abramoff is actually the
inventor of Redux he wrote a post quite
a little bit after he was like chill
people Redux has a reason it doesn't
have to go in every app if you don't
have to deal with a lot of states that
is across several components don't use
Redux this tool has a purpose and my
most favorite tool that I use every day
is probably the web itself so in
December 2017 HTML 5.2 was released and
what was in there
well the dialog was element wasn't then
I'm really excited about this one
because this will finally solve the
model problem right so how can I use the
dialog element so here you see the
dialog element this is hidden by user
default style sheets of the browser's
then we can grab this element just from
the Dom and this then has functions
available like show modal
close this is solving the Moodle problem
and it then has some styling properties
that I can use to finally solve the
issue of overlays and when you use that
you see it in action and this doesn't
look very fancy but this solves also all
the problems that the good modal brings
with you a good model doesn't allow that
you can tap out of the model and access
the content behind that that is really
hard to do a good model is focusable
when you open it all these kind of
things are going into the platform
itself and I think this is really
exciting what is the support for the
dialog element today but it is poly
fillable and maybe you don't want to
reinvent the wheel and you want to play
or you want to bet on the platform
itself if you want to know what was and
what was added to the spec there's this
really nice blog post which I highly
recommend but then also we have new CSS
and 2018 available which is great right
we finally made it so you see an example
of my private website did you see this
long container on the right side this is
just a long unordered list there are no
floats no additional markup it's just a
clean clean list so how can I can I
reuse CSS grid today well it's display
grid and then there's this property that
is called a grid template columns and I
can say that I want to repeat all the
entries I want to make them out of scale
without a fit and then there's this
magic thing called min Max and then I
can define okay I want the containers
the items be at least 20 M but it should
not be bigger than one fret if fractions
so what that means is that everything
scales automatically and it will just
fit into the container and follow the
grid this is making a restaurant
responsive with four lines of CSS and
then you can also do cool stuff like
this so you can define for example grid
Row and what I'm doing there is
shorthand for this basically I'm
defining this container the red one
there and it should start at the second
row and it should end at the fifth row
this is super cool no additional markup
required so what's the support for grid
um if you want to learn grid the best
resource that I think is out there is
West boss he does online videos and his
CSS great course is really valuable and
you can the videos already short so you
can learn this step by step by step then
we have also focused within and this CSS
rule I couldn't be less excited when I
saw this for the first time so what this
gives us gives you a hook to figure out
when you have an element and something
inside of this element is focusable
right so the use case you see there is
that I'm highlighting the parent
container when the input in this
container has focus and I was like yeah
that's not too exciting but with focus
within we maybe can finally figure out
CSS drop down menus
because with a little bit of nifty css3
career this works without JavaScript I
can tap into this first list element and
then the one below opens and it stays
open because I can use focus within if
you interested how do you do these kind
of things with CSS only and make them
keyboard accessible because that's the
trick here and this article is really
nice so what's the support for focus
within
polyfill the wall I think this is super
cool so what I want to tell you is that
today and I'm watching specs and
browsers evolve and really really
closely evergreen browsers evolve
quickly and just because I have a little
red cross here now doesn't mean that the
Red Cross is there next month or in six
month but also Java Script evolved right
and we now have finally Exim ACMA Script
modules import statements right dealing
with modules and dependencies in the
browser and how does that work in the
front-end world right we can include the
scripts and then there's this new thing
called type module which the browser
picks up when it supports modules and
then there's also for legacy stuff for
browsers that don't support it there's
the no module attribute this little line
or this element has a few
different things to deal with though so
JavaScript that runs in this file is
strict mode by default so we can drop
you strict this on top level is
undefined
there's the variables on top level there
are only local to the script
they are always loaded asynchronous so
no need for async or defer to not block
rendering and they execute after the
HTML is finished parsing so even when
you have an inline script with type
module it won't be executed before the
HTML is done with parsing what support
do I have it's the air that's super cool
does that now mean that we move away
from bundling and should throw out all
the build process out of the window no
it doesn't I spent last year weeks
researching this so if you want to know
how this affects your build process you
can read this article but on the other
hand actually this happened today event
view is the maintainer of view GS he
will make new build possible that use
this because then we can save a little
bit of boilerplate right this is code we
don't have to execute to make modules
work in browsers another thing that I'm
excited about today is actually types in
JavaScript I'm a JavaScript developer
for quite a while and I was like always
like ah that's fine I can deal with
JavaScript right but then typescript
came along and I was always like who
needs those things I mean it worked
before but a month ago I opened the pull
request in our ecosystem and you see
that this pull requests at 21 change
files and what I did is I changed this
function so this is typescript the
beauty of typescript is that it works
with JavaScript and then you can just
add types step by step by step and this
definition there actually says that the
async function migration accepts the
argument migration Creator of type
function and returns a promise that
resolves with a collection of typed
intent and I changed this one function
and I thought well this is not a big
deal and I changed it to this
and what happened is that everything
broke because typescript was smart
enough to figure out that I changed the
signature this is for people coming from
other languages constantly for a
JavaScript developer this is magic and
web pack for example recently switched
to typescript 2 and just by switching to
typescript they found nine bucks that I
didn't know about just because
typescript checked their codebase this
can bring you a lot of safety and the
obvious one for typescript is you get
out of completion right so what for
JavaScript developer that's a big deal
so you what you see there is that I use
the content full SDK I create a client
and I get really nice auto completion
down the tree below which tells me what
I can use in here so there's a response
and I know that this responses items and
the first item has fields and I can go
down the tree this brings a lot of
productivity in JavaScript land so when
you're building large-scale JavaScript
egg apps take all the safety and help
you can get because this UPS shipping
better products also very popular last
year PvP lwas progressive web apps right
they were everywhere my friend all I
gave a talk about that she just said PW
is something something just google it
because you find enough resources for
that progressive relevance have three
main things so they're reliable they
work offline and they are fast
so it's cutting edge JavaScript and then
they're engaging with post push
notification on something so progressive
web apps are basically the web approach
for shipping apps that feel native and
the core technology of progressive web
apps and I've never thought that I will
show this slide but today is the day
basically the serviceworker is the core
of focuses web apps it's in the middle
and it sits between the browser and the
internet and with this you can interfere
requests that are going out and you can
define caching behavior which helps you
to make things work serviceworker was or
was a hot topic last year and was always
is it ready
and was not until a few months back and
Jake Archibald is maintaining this
resource here and he gives you all the
information to know is this supported
now can we write progressive rabbits and
when you google this what you find out
out there is these kind of low-level
code snippets this is how you define a
service worker you say that I want to
listen to a fetch event and then I want
to do this or this or this and I do
think that it is important to know how
this works but we are now at the stage
that we use different tools on top of
that so what you see there is work box
that's a project maintained by Google
and all I have to do to make a web app
or website offline capable is these four
or five lines of JavaScript I'm this is
inside of my serviceworker a service
workers just a JavaScript file that you
load I load the library and I say please
for these routes go with a strategy
network first this means that the
service worker that sits between me and
the internet tries to fetch the file but
if it's not there it used it uses a
cache version and this means with these
few lines I'll just make my website
offline capable I think this is super
super cool who is running progressive
Rebbetzin production just a heads up
there's a breaking change so usually
what happens is when you visit a
progressive web app is that at some
point a banner pops up that tells oh hey
do you want to install this app the user
doesn't know that it's progressive
revurb is just installing the thing and
usually this happens automatically but
there's no breaking change which means
that you have to take care of that so
just a heads up so what I want to tell
you is know the tools but then trust
what is done what is out there already
when you're building progress web apps
you're usually running on a kind of
recent front and stack anyways and
you're probably working with some api's
and there's this buzzword hanging around
right so graph QL is a new way on how we
deal with ap is and recently I was
reading an article and that was
published by Airbnb so there's this
dialogue so there's a back end engineers
who says so you're saying this graph QL
will allow any web or native engineer to
surely query basically any fields and
any back-end servers recursively however
they want without any backends
engineering the world yep
this is what it is so this is the world
where I'm coming from right I'm building
a web app and I fetch resources one
request per resource step by step when
you're building a complex JavaScript app
this is a lot of requests that are
flying there and then the most API
driven the most restful IPS I work with
then kind of work around rest and
include a query parameter that is kind
of includes or select that Slim's down
the payload a little bit so this is just
hacking kind of rest so with graph QL
this all changes to something like this
so there's one request it is a post
because graph QL and points also allow
you to mutate date this is a little bit
tricky but yeah and then you define
query inside of your request and what
you see there is that I want to have a
course with the ID whatever and I want
to have the title the slug and the level
I am in the front and can decide what
data I want to have and this works
recursively down the tree and this is
then the response which gives a lot of
power and flexibility in the front-end
also graph QL comes with this really
nifty tool that is called graphical a
graphical graph QL endpoint also has a
schema definition which means that with
this I can just open graphical with a
graphical endpoint I can see what data I
can't vary and it's self documenting
this can be increase your productivity
enormously so I truly believe that graph
QL will change the way we work
completely
and over the last year or two
also new approaches to static sites
appeared gem stack was a topic two years
ago and I get it it's getting hot again
so when I built my first static site
this is what I did so I had some
templates and content files markdown
usually then I brought an instead excite
generator and then I got a website right
cool but when I wanted to add some
functionality or I wanted to style it or
I wanted to do
something that it was not supported by
the static site generator I added my
assets which went into gulp or grunt if
someone remembers these and now I had
two different things right templating on
the server side for the static site
generator let's say in Hamel or
something else and templating in my
JavaScript thing when I click a button I
think I'm moving too much on the stage
here which meant that I had a constant
context switch when you have two meant I
had to maintain templates twice not only
in one company so what we can do now is
also when you want to bring API data in
this approach what you had to do is you
had to write this API there this API
data to to disk
so that the static site generator can
pick it up and then in the front-end you
just use it and with standard Ajax let's
change that cool doesn't work all right
yeah
I think this is a message downside
because I'm dealing with API data every
day so what we have now that we can
unify these two contexts finally because
we have universal JavaScript apps
completely JavaScript right JavaScript
on the server side JavaScript on the
front and then how it works is that you
use the stuff that runs in the browser
later generate static HTML with it and
then the chip front-end JavaScript kicks
in and it does the process that is
called hydration and then it just moves
the over the HTML you just served and
this way you can solve these problems
that I just described so we can then
surf
I'm not a lucky person today you can't
serve static HTML you have a unified
code base so the same code runs on your
server side for generation and the
browser the developer tooling we have in
JavaScript land is today I don't want to
develop websites without hot reloading
anymore this is super cool we've got an
extremely rich ecosystem and p.m.
there's always a package for that and we
can use cutting-edge technologies quite
easily because these new tools are ready
for that I also wrote about that if
you're if you're interested so what
tools I am talking about here the most
present ones are next and next and
Gatsby yes so next is develop outside
and it's react based can be used as a
static site generators next is just a
view ecosystem trolling next so don't be
confused there and then there's Gatsby
and Gatsby kind of is the most
successful one today because it moves
the whole thing to a new level it's
based on react and you can ship a
progressive web app that gets all the
good performance scores with just
enabling a plugin this is super nice and
it bets also on graph girl so this is
the current front-end static site
hipster stack if you're interested in
this so in the front-end world today I
think that every web site is a web app
and every web app is a web site which
doesn't mean that you have to ship a
bunch of JavaScript files all the time
because you can still ship only HTML but
you can use the technology you use every
day
when you use these tools you will hit a
wall at some point though because you
have to configure a lot of things and
this is why there is a new trend going
on that is called zero convex JavaScript
and the biggest problem we had were
bundlers so bundlers or build tools are
the tools that take all the files and
that make a nice small thing that runs
performant lis right and the tool that
you that wins the race today is web pack
and web pack get so much out of hand
that people make jokes out of it
so people call themself senior web pack
conflict manager or execute execute of
rep pack configuration engineer tweets
like this are everywhere right because
web pack can be extremely hard to work
with what happens if a tool gets so
popular and it has some obvious issues
where the competition starts right so
what I want to show you is parcel which
is which is a tool that I use for
prototyping today and I'm doing a live
demo so let's see how this goes so what
you see here is my terminal yeah that
works so let's go to a directory that I
don't have to delete later
all right and let's create some files
here and let's yeah these this look
actually not too bad cool so let's open
these and my editor here so what what
wait a second what do we have here so
I'm using vias code cool so we have few
files here right and I want to start my
journey with the index.html and because
I don't want to type everything let's
just the parcel let's just do this all
this what this does it includes and
index.js file right so let's go to next
Jes and let's say import Maine from
Maine yes and then let's execute this
and then let's go to Maine GS
export default let's define a function
and let's create an element maybe
console M document create element if
it's at a class here food let's set some
inner text here I was up and then let's
just add this element to the body Alam
but now we're missing some styling right
so let's just go import styles from when
words called main CSS where is that not
highlighting and let's just say foo
color red cool something obvious right
here
and port styles from taupe so let's go
in here and let's just run parcel
centric site lighting is not working so
this problem breaks let's see no okay
and I've got a URL here right which is
my local environment let's open this did
anyone see them error sure web all right
like that so more all right so let's see
if that works is it red nice so what
just happened is that I just defined one
single HTML file and parcel figure all
the rest it checked all right there's a
JavaScript file cool as CSS I should
deal with this probably too and there
are some other JavaScript files and I
won't resolve these and make a proper
nice bundle all of that and it works
with typescript sauce all 0 config this
is super super nice so when you have
competition in the tooling space that's
always a good thing right so Shawn
Larkin one of the maintainer epic
figured out well we should maybe fix
something here so web pack also improves
just because um parcel showed up and the
tools to set exciting raters that I just
showed you also updated to web pack for
them and all the fancy new technologies
like code splitting and serving several
bundles for different routes and all
these kind of things you get these with
these new tools for free today and when
we talk about 0 config we also have to
talk about toolkits starting a react app
was extremely tedious last year ago
right
but then create react type appears which
is zero conflict generator to start your
react applications without all the
hassle to figure out what tools should I
use and then the same happen for view
and pre act and then you've got your
project running in two minutes
zero configuration and when you look
into these what you will find is that
all the dependencies
and all the tools abstracted away to
make it easier to develop they provide a
lot of things out of a box and you only
have to deal with a single dependency
then so called a toolkit if you're
interested in to read more about this
there's this really nice github
repository and there are a lot of
starters zero conflict to get you
started so what I want to tell you is
that when you choose your tools a good
tool should just work
but then should be highly configurable
when you have to scale it up so when you
were building your apps then you also
want to be on the safe side right so new
automation tools also appeared and what
you should probably do when you run a
big app in production is you should
write end-to-end tests and I love
writing end-to-end tests right it said
no one ever
and there's a new tool out there that is
called Cyprus in Cyprus literally blew
my mind because with Cyprus it actually
becomes fun again so let's just quit
this and let's go to my private website
and let's open this so what you see is
my private website and it includes a
Cyprus config somewhere there which is
currently empty
because I didn't configure much and then
there's this Cyprus folder which has a
few things like fixtures and plugins
they are not really important right now
and then there's a test file so what we
can do now is we can just I have Cypress
installed globally so let's kick that
off and let's see what happens
Cyprus is based on electron but works
with all the other with browsers too
so what you see here let me just move
that over is a project management window
and this is basically the test file you
just saw and when I kick this off on its
again here when I kick this off you see
the interface of Cyprus so what you see
on the right side is an real browser and
the test case that I just wrote and the
cool thing about that is that I can
inspect the browser at the point in time
of the test case so let's just write
some tests now here so what you see here
is
I want to test the headline I'm visiting
this website and I've got this sigh
element available which lets me query
the Dom so I can just say okay h1 cool
but let's move via skirt to the left
side now that didn't turn out well and
that's the wrong window here we go
so let's just get the h1 and let's check
if it contains my name and when I now go
open Cyprus on the right-hand side you
see that it automatically queries what
is going on and I see and can inspect
everything that happens there so let's
write another test which is like sigh
gate h1 let's grab the length of all the
elements that are in there its length
should equal 1 right because you should
only have one h1 in your document cool
so let's break that
sweet with Cypress you can develop your
entrant s next to each other and you
have also the functionality to record
videos of your runs this all comes
automatically with Cypress I think this
is really exciting if you're interested
to learn and see how to get started with
Cypress this is glad bamboo Tov he's the
VP of engineering of Cypress and he took
30 minutes of time and we set Cypress up
for my site this is really valuable if
you want to start playing around with
this but it's not only end-to-end
testing I think the stack today is also
about utilities so last week or
something I had this discussion at
contentful and we published an article
with a broken link right how often does
that happen so I was like can we make
that please part of the manual checklist
of the editors and Chris he's the CMO it
was like no dude that's the wrong
approach that doesn't scale let's
automate that right so who remembers
phantoms yes I was a big fan of phantoms
yes so but phantom jet was basically a
headless webkit browser that you can't
control and script unfortunately it's
not maintained anymore because chrome
got a headless mode and the chrome folks
or the Google folks are now maintaining
puppeteer which is a nice interface on
top of a headless Chrome which means
that you can automate whatever you want
with it with a real chrome so this is
how this works you have to just grab
puppeteer define the URL then you launch
the browser open a new page and then you
define the go to the URL you wait until
all the network is done and then you
close the window again this is all it
takes to open up a new browser so let's
just evaluate all the URLs that are in
the page and evaluate is crucial here
because now we're switching context from
node to the website itself so this stuff
runs in the website are just opened so I
get all the links there I grabbed all
the href and then I'm using assets to
get all out of to get rid of all the
duplicates so I've now a lot of URLs
then I bring in note fetch and I check
hey do all these URLs give me a 200 when
I run a request them and map that and
then I'm filtering out all the valid
ones
and then I'm just writing an
console.log message right so with these
few lines of JavaScript this actually
opens up a browser that I don't see and
tells me what links are broken on my
side this is super cool for automation
but the Google folks also maintain this
repository here which is puppeteer
examples so maybe you want to automate
to figure out how much not used CSS and
JavaScript you have on your site or
maybe you want to create big big
sitemaps you could say well I could do
this with curl which is not true when
you have some clients I'm rendering in
place right with this you can do this
maybe you want to check if your service
worker and your offline capabilities are
working correctly or you want to just
compare yourself with your competitors
and I think this is really cool so you
can load several windows side by side
and just because you can run headless
but you don't have to so you see here
that I open two pages next to each other
and I see how fast they load and I have
information available in how fast they
load and I can dig into that if I want
to so what I want to tell you in this
section is automate everything and spend
your time with fun stuff I would say
though that this is very very much fun
stuff and another big word last year and
the rule continuous cyril s right
horrible name with different meanings
for different people but I think Chris
Koya has the best explanation here and
he said well serverless you can take a
front-end skills and two things that
typically only back-end developer can do
cool and then I saw this tree by Daniel
he's from Oslo as they may be here I
think that would be fun okay he said
that several as basically means I'm a
JavaScript F and everything is logos
Legos cool so what what does that mean
so let's take the JavaScript engineers
out there what we can do now is we can
just play with Legos so this is Google
Cloud aw as an azure not my first choice
because it's a little bit too
complicated sometimes but if I want to
host the static site I would go for
nightly file which we will see in a
second for no devs I would go with site
which is also I can deploy it node apps
really really quickly that are scalable
for content management I would go with
content full
for fast search implementing a really
fast search is really hard alle Golia is
doing a good job here for authentication
maybe I don't want to do with the
database and stuff I can go with
all-zero
and for sending SMS and communication
stuff right I could go with Trillium
there is a service for that I don't have
to reinvent the wheel so let's have a
quick look how can i as a front-end
developer deploy sites quickly so we
have for example these two out there for
awhile
we've got searching pita pages which let
me deploy files really easily just push
them or call a command but these always
had the problem that I had to connect
them with the with a CI service that
actually deploys the things when I
commit something to repository Nataly
find out comes along and it ships with
CI included which means then when you're
going static you can get your static
sites in minutes with nightly fine
because you just have to connect you
define the command you want to run and
you get HTTP to HTTPS and all the
goodies for free and for no that's I go
with site so what you see here is a
repository that only includes two files
it's a package JSON that uses micro
which is a really slim down HTTP library
and I'm exporting one file and
index.html in XJS and it just deployed
this thing I've got my own URL which I
can now access now inside provides
something really really nice so when you
go to underscore source you can expect
all the files that you just deployed I
think this is super cool and share the
URLs them and also all these tools a lot
of these tools are based on docker which
means that they are not throwing them
away
we're not deploying our change but now
outside I just get a different URL Andy
stay there forever which is super cool
when you want for example have different
environments like your staging or your
pull request these are still layers so
you see there are two deployed sites
with two different URLs that I just
deployed in a few minutes without
knowing how to do def up stuff so but
talking about server lists we have to
talk function as a service right which
is a little bit scary for me but I think
it's actually I'm it's not that bad
so everything is based on a function so
you see here's javascript that just
exports the function say hello
well run this in AWS this is then a
lambda function and to make this is
accessible to the Internet what we have
to do is we have to configure API
gateway I think this is a horrible
complicated sounding name when I heard
that for the first time I was like yeah
I'm not sure if I can deal with that now
let's just quickly switch that and bring
in a status code and serve some JSON and
then we can go over to AWS and configure
these things right when you go to AWS
this is what you get when I open that
for the first time I was like oh boy
when you make your way through this you
find eventually this little editor for
the function and this configuration for
API gateway but working solace in this
environment can be a little bit tedious
because you have to jump between windows
and you have to set up a lot of thoughts
and yeah and this is why we have
frameworks on top of that so this is the
serverless framework right just bring in
another word that includes serverless
which works with Google Cloud editor yes
Microsoft and IBM and we've got Claudia
J's which works with AWS only and I'm
using today server less with AWS so how
hard is it for me to deploy a function
in AWS right that's one one Yama file I
define the service I defined an old
version and I did find what HTTP methods
I want to have and I've got the same and
largess file here so I can then use the
serverless CRI and I can deploy the
thing and I'm not scared anymore
because this actually works quite fall
asleep so what I do now add content for
quite a while is I'm pushing functions
everywhere right and when I did it for
the first time our one of our sister
plans came to me Jevon how did you
configure API gate where I was like I
configured what but he was really smart
and this is how it should be he didn't
give me enough access to be dangerous
anyways right he was just like yeah go
with it roll with it
this is a really nice tag if you need an
endpoint that does something this is
really really nice because then you can
connect all the dots
and several s technologies work a lot
with webhooks today so what I had as a
use case was we have the Disco's forum
and I needed slack integration right two
posts new posts to our slack now this
course has a slack integration but only
for one slack org and we've got two
slackers one internal one and one
external one so I wrote myself a lambda
function really quickly that pushed this
stuff back so how much and now I've got
the flexibility to distribute that data
wherever one right it's just JavaScript
and I can use the node echo system to do
whatever I want in it so I just created
a function that is called handle this
course then I passed whatever I get from
this course I get the data I'm
interested in and then I posted to slack
this took me three four hours and is now
part of our ecosystem and the result is
this I think this is beautiful so
remember the example when I started the
headless chrome I have that running in
the cloud - so I've got an endpoint but
and I think we can kick that mm-hmm
let's whoa now fix it up so when I go
now here what is happening copied the
wrong one right
so we're not going over here sue Brooke
I messed up the URL okay I'm sorry about
that
and I messed up my timer now so when I'm
going over time you have to know let me
know so the mantra we have in the front
end team right now is just write a
lambda function for it lambda functions
you pay them only when they run so if
you have function hanging around that
are not executed well it is like that
but let me ask you a question
could we build stuff for the web without
a local set up running completely
serverless so we have tools like J's bin
and jsfiddle and code pen available for
riot right but there's this new tool
that is called cool code sandbox has
anyone you said this is too good so
let's go to code sandbox to enter enter
code
sandbox so what I can do here is I can
create a new sandbox and I want to go
with react right and now I've got a
really nice editor with all the tools
already set up and I'm going to change
something here
yo yo yo yo cool this works I've got a
nice preview environment now available
the cool thing about code sandbox is
look at this ha
so let's just define a name here for and
let's make that bigger because probably
cannot see that so let's go and you see
our slow demo 3 and let's go to github
so when I going on here here we go
can I now wear ascots and box here we go
so what if I want to make commits that
also works update so how do I deploy
that now
well Nedley fine okay so let's go to
next if I and that's important new site
from get alright let's go with this one
here and let's go with NDC and you see
how did I call it is this one way all
right so let's connect that this now
lets me define a built command which is
built in this case which is by accident
the default of the create reactor of an
area of code sandbox and pod and it
defines the folder that I want to
publish to the Internet
okay next leaf owner also sets all the
web box so when a commit comes into
github it will automatically start a new
builds so let's commit something else
so let's commit that again yeah come on
Wi-Fi
okay but what if and I want to make that
editable for example because now I have
to do github changes here right to
update contents in the headline I could
also use now contentful which I have
open here somewhere already and I could
create a new space let's call it NDC
Oslo demo and what I can do is I can
just define the data I want to deal with
so for example I want to write a new
page now cool and let's just define some
fields that I need to use my react app
so let's call it title and let's call it
body this accepts markdown later on so
let's configure that save that
let's go to create a new page let's go
with NDC yo what's up let's publish that
so now can go back to code sandbox let's
make this a little bit smaller here and
let's just remove that for a second and
let go with snippets check so what I did
here is I brought in a new dependency
we'll just create with the fruits
handles with markdown so let's just
quickly install that so where's the
button react markdown cool and let's add
the content for dependency content it's
full I'm at some time by the way cool so
now I have to create a client to get to
have to get the rights to get the data
back so let's just quickly do this so
what we can do is we can grab the space
ID a space this bucket of data oops
so which we can define here
and let's define an access token which
we can get in the access settings here
and here
keep doing that cool now we've got a
token let's save that and feel like I'm
messing that up but let's see so let's
go to the entry that we just created and
let's grab the idea of this one because
this is what what we want to use and
I'll keep doing that
let's go here
and here we have the data we just
created right and the cool thing about
this is now when we go to nightly Phi
this is also deployed already so when we
go here I want built-in RAM but you can
then connect all the all the dots and
you have a set up running without any
file on your local computer in a few
minutes when you connect all the dots so
the setup would be that you create your
code in code side box you're
automatically connected with github you
push it with web hooks you trigger new
builds then you can bring in content
full to get fresh data so that editors
have an interface to edit the data and
content for can then sent another web
box to notify and this one our percent
serverless without any files on your
computer so what I want to say is that
you should spend time building your
businesses and not reinventing the wheel
and so when you look out there this is a
really nice resource when you want to
get started with serverless it's done by
Chris Koya and code pan actually also
has equipment projects which is
currently in beta so this website that
you saw just before is developed in code
pen to prod with cold pen and it's all
running in the cloud at a super cool so
this was this for 2018 so what is my
wish for the future that we finally
figure this out so web components are a
way to define native components with the
platform we have and custom elements
play a big big role in this so you can
then just define your
components with behavior and styles and
shipped them without the need of any
framework and the support of these is
really not that bad so then we can
finally figure out the date picker
discussion right so not three four five
day Pickers
but one day picker that reps a web
component a new framework that is out
there that is called stencil and Dominic
will talk about stencil tomorrow at
10:20 Dominic still there oh so if
you're interested in the new power of
web components I highly recommend check
that out so let's all bet on the
platform because I think this is the
future in the long run and random
anyways so to close the whole thing what
I want to tell you is the pace of the
fronton world is horrible but don't
worry to fall behind because what James
said is very very true just deal with it
choose your tools wisely and acknowledge
that you cannot be always cutting edge
it's not possible there's too much stuff
out there and just use what works for
you and that's it thank you
I was I was said that you should rate
this talk with the paper thing is there